[Music]
you are meant to be a celebrity
hello hello hello and welcome back to
the break room we're so glad to see your
roomies breakers all you fans out there
all your wife john fans
there's less and less of those every day
welcome back to the break room our daily
show that keeps you updated on just
what's going on in nerd news and you
know what we want to say a happy 616 to
all you true believers out there
uh we're in the 616 the mcu's in the 616
the comic books are in the 616. it's all
616 baby area code 616. if you happen to
live there hello
if i had better cell coverage i'd give
you a call sometime coming up on the
show today venom is entering trilogy
territory we've been warned uh and we've
got tons to talk about of episode two of
miss marvel wasn't it great wasn't it
wonderful but before we get to all that
we got to say hello to all of my friends
joining us today here on the break room
live from our burial break room at new
rockstars headquarters we have whitney
van laningham oh no the note flying in
oh yes say hello whitney say hi sorry i
was looking at this like oh
i'm sorry i had to look at it i just
transported back to junior high i
already feel the same thing that's all
right we also have tommy bechtol hey
everybody great to be back i wanted to
give him camera for a second yesterday i
said that the people watching the show
were trash people oh my gosh no lie i
don't recall that with no lies and no
personalities and meaningless in a world
of celebrity and sexy fascinating
limousine lifestyles and i want to say
i'm sorry about that oh my god everyone
that watches this show is important to
me even you worthless bland beige
soulless humans that are just exist as
binary code to me and that would never
impact my real life i'm sorry that i
besmirched you i don't think you're
worthless i just think you don't matter
what an intro uh thank you so much tommy
for your your two cents
uh we also have jessica clements on the
show today my con is hot check one two
one two um my birthday's in binary code
oh yeah yeah zero one one zero oh okay i
mean i think you could put all birthdays
in binary cards yeah there's only zeros
and ones you're born january 10th yeah
people are going to steal your identity
out there you got to watch out you
better watch out
uh we got a lot to talk about today
we're going to talk about episode 2 of
miss marvel we saved it for today so we
hope you've all seen it out there uh
before we get to that uh our chat
redemption today as it is most days is
the swear jar what's the swear jar we
are not allowed to curse on the break
room it's forbidden notes have come down
from management it says too much cursing
on the break room but
if we raise at least 100 in super chats
we'll let a curse out of the jar yeah
the swear jar if you will and it's a and
it's an escalating sword oh and it's an
escalator you get to 100 we'll make 200
special you get to 200 we'll make your
discussion we're going to tell you what
yeah yeah you got to earn what yeah yeah
you got to earn it mo on the board
emma's already a background trash person
giving you money emma you're my favorite
kind of background trash person my
favorite trash person is sean greener
who just in the chat said when i die
throw me in the trash
that's like one of the greatest tweets
of all time was just found out coffins
cost 10 grand don't worry about a fan
when i die burying me loose
i'm sure you can find a refrigerator box
for me somewhere the government does
have strict regulations about where you
can put dead bodies most cities have
very strict zoning lawsuits do be
careful about that doctor strange didn't
care doctor says okay
well in new york city you're allowed to
put a body wherever you want
you're encouraged to put the bodies in
creative hey we got a lot to talk about
today
so let's get into it the headlines
pause for graphic venom franchise star
tom hardy will serve as co-writer on the
upcoming third movie in the franchise we
know he's been kind of rewriting scripts
as he goes he's officially a co-writer
on the third movie uh he took to social
media today to share a glimpse of the
title page for the new film with the
title itself blacked out show us the
title you coward
show us the title
he did it uh we're excited for for venom
three i think we're right we asked you
guys in the chat who you'd like to see
is villains and uh uh
part three of the venom trilogy yes um
sam battenfield taking toxin for the
venom three villain it seems very
similar it seems like the right way to
go or spider-man is the antagonist i
don't know i don't know uh bryce burris
saying have no be the behind the curtain
villain sending symbiotes to catch venom
and bring him to the man spider man
spider i love the little man spider yeah
that would be great that would be great
uh eminem was recently in the minions
movie oh
his third villain should be eminem yes
because then it would just really bring
a full circle i mean they need a song of
eminem and venom rapping together that's
what we're missing if venom came out in
the 90s
uh venom would be featured on the the
song with eminem for sure
next headline next headline uh in her
new teen vogue first interview uh macy
williams opened up about the first time
she was ever surprised by her game of
thrones character arya stark uh she said
quote the first time i was surprised by
arya i guess was probably in the final
series when she whips off her clothes
and sleeps with gendry spoiler alert if
you haven't watched the final series uh
maisie said in the video with an ironic
chuckle quote i thought that arya was
queer you know so yeah that was surprise
maisy ads shrugging i'll do a shrug
drugging
i think we were all surprised by seeing
her whip off her clothes i the first
thing i thought was like how old is this
character right yeah you gotta rush to
the internet someone sometimes held this
character yeah yeah i mean i feel like
if it was on hbo we probably should have
known probably at least 18 but we
shouldn't know we should have known we
got we got i'm sorry we got to go back
real quick okay i know we're trying to
get through this but joel joel fernandez
gave us 50 dollars whoa
sony is the greatest villain to the
venom franchise you guys are the ghosts
i would love to see an anthropomorphic
zoning take on yes
i am amy pascal
i have come to destroy you
also shout out to corey westerol that
said super trash with the tm so it's you
know it's real it's legit yes in the
super chat oh i mean we've been trying
to call you guys breakers or roomies but
if you want to be known as super trash
let us know how to be the trash bags
they are i'm the trash man
and i did pick up the garbage
uh we can
boots always saying you stay tuned for
the channel for our holy sunny breakdown
one of these days new headline chongqi
and the legend of the ten rings
filmmaker destin daniel creditor king
new headline
daniel
daniel crenton has teamed up with andrew
guest a writer producer on comedy such
as brooklyn nine-nine and i lost my
cursor uh
and community to tackle a live-action
series featuring the long-time marvel
character wait for it you've been
begging for it wonder man that's right
guests will serve as had writer of the
series while [ __ ] will executive
produce and possibly direct on an
episode or more this was late breaking
news just before the break i'm not
trying to be that person but i saw one
person in the chat excited for wonder
man and you are lying
i don't know eric's already uh he's he's
burning his books he's making a video
about wonder man right now he'll
probably be up on the channel tomorrow
oh i think
wonder man
i can already see the thumbnail an arrow
why is he wonderful yeah
uh why is he why is he wondering is he
wonderful is he wonderful
all right enough of that topic new
headline
hidden in the episode of miss marvel is
a qr code that directs you to a digital
comic book uh we want to discuss these
qr easter eggs real fast uh and their
meaning for the series cause there's
been two already two different comic
books they did this at moonlight as well
you may recall
uh
and our question really here is like do
any of these comic books have like plot
implications
jessica what for example uh in the issue
that the qr code led to for this most
recent episode comrade led kamala to the
villain after kabala had followed him in
his after kamala had followed him in his
car in the previous issue and kamran is
revealed to be the villain as well yes
this episode that we saw ended with
kamala going to cameron's car is she in
danger because she saw the woman in the
back who's like i've been looking for
him
are you looking at me to confirm what in
the comments well do you think they're
trying to like tell us he's a villain
yeah no 100 and that it follows exactly
what happened in the comic book the only
which is i don't
it's not really a spoiler i'm just
saying i mean it's in the comments in
the comment box this was just in the
comic book was that he threw up the
spoilers real fast he's he led her to
the compound that had like an inhuman
leader who was like basically wilson
fisk but like
extra extra inhuman and so that version
in this is her is the mom and i think
it's better that it's the mom of camera
camera
way more fun because i mean it shows
like i'm not going to betray my mama
yeah right he did it for his mama and if
anything we know that the mcu they like
to use the comics as like a foundation
and then subvert our expectation because
they know we're reading they're they're
keeping really close though we don't
want to read they know several of us
know how to read somebody somebody is
pretty close
keep apologizing quick
it keeps uh they're they're keeping
pretty close to the comic books it's
just hard when it's like she's inhuman
and we also have wolverine so they like
took those parts out but they did a
really good job of putting other things
in yeah i mean they've introduced black
bolt he's yeah
that's what i always say
anyway someone in the chat said that
they knew wonder man from the marvel
dice game and i don't know are we
talking 711 or 456. which marvel doesn't
like a marvel dice four five six there's
a seven eleven because it matters
seven eleven is very simple straight up
like crap seven eleven you crap out or
you win automatically rather snake guys
you crap out 456 you know you're going
for pairs and then the top than the top
number on the third dice uh we're gonna
do a whole inside dice games coming up
next week
can i just uh say thank you to mr feeney
for the 20
asking what happened to zach is he in
witness protection yes we he is he's in
whit pro and you can't tell him they're
a witness protector yeah i know he's in
bakersfield right yeah he said he's
written he's in the denny's is real
wondering right for anime if you're
wandering around uh bakersfield right
now and you see a large muscular man
beating up on trains lifting them above
his head to keep it to keep him fine for
him
that's our baby boy zach and send them
home send them home we promise not to
ride them outside
yeah we won't you can have them no one
gets a fidget paper
next headline amman valani has shown am
i saying your name right here i'm so bad
eric says it right i'm on bolani yeah
yeah she did say that you're watching
and i'm so sorry i'm not as good as eric
amman valani has shown a huge fan of
shown to be a huge fan of the marvel
cinematic universe even in the point
that she was streaming mcu shows on her
phone during breaks while filming miss
marvel this was the quote from kevin
feige or from her
uh or someone said no it's from uh it's
from the guy who plays your brother the
guy who plays her brother oh name not
given quote i'll tell you a secret kevin
feige got mad at her for watching one
division on her phone fulani's co-star
cigar
chic
cigar shake shake shake i apologize
told marvel.com about the mcu superfan
he also said he's like they're not made
for phones watch it on tv that's true
that's true that is true how do you guys
in the chat watch the emcee i watch it
if it's like oh for a lot of moon night
because i need to see i have horrible
ice i have to see closer i literally
watch it under my covers and my phone in
my hand and i'm like this far from my
face oh okay so only sometimes but it is
meant for tv it is meant for tvs i you
know for work i have to watch it as
quick as i can a lot of times a lot of
times i'm watching that on my phone but
then i watch it again later with my wife
and it's like a nice to see it small
first and then big i'll be having a nice
upgrade i'll watch mine on my apple
watch oh okay
i gotta i got an ipod video uh third
generation it's not bad
if david lynch could hear this
conversation he'd come break all of our
necks oh
my gosh
he is famous for that david lynch is not
a hat care
before david
i hope david lynch is watching what's
the weather today david
uh we broke the switch i bless you all
thank you all so much
tommy gets the curse all right well let
me call out some specific people alex c
goddamn trash
christopher morris trash bag [ __ ] bag
andy's daily i don't know the tv
that's too [ __ ] bad
alex again go after yourself i'll censor
myself to ask feel bad my mom watches
this and she said maybe i've done too
many of these swearing montages and it's
time to get creative you know what i say
you know my [ __ ] boss mom i'm 38
years old i can do what i want i can put
my own shirts on hello i can go i can
eat whatever goddamn food i want
okay maybe i am a piece of [ __ ] maybe i
am
god he's cutting a promo on his own
mother
oh my gosh yes thank you to our super
chatters uh charlie 836 sending in the
woman in the vision kamala had is that
comrades couple more payments does that
get your ass frozen me
[ __ ] all right i'm done does that
mean that they're related ew i was
rooting for them we might we'll maybe
talk about that a little bit yeah we'll
talk about it i don't think it's far
enough away
also if you really want to learn about
it you can tune in to rogue theory oh
world theory we go into it this week uh
michael canning also sent a super chat
remember my trash friends it's called a
garbage can not a garbage can not that's
the positive wow positivity we like to
see from our super trash trash you guys
let me see your
lids bang
this isn't stop this isn't stop it's
time for the discussion oh you have time
for the major discussion put up that
spoiler bar because we're talking about
miss marvel episode two we're gonna dive
deeper into it we did a little bit
yesterday with no spoilers but today we
are going to include a lot of spoilers
in particularly we're going to talk
about uh cleary's enhanced list so if
you don't remember um the very racist
people that said a very racist thing
that were
also in spiderman no way home the deal
that's the dodc yeah the the department
of
control the department of damage control
who we saw ages ago in iron man uh they
were known as the just damage control
now they are the department of damage
control which cleans up the messes
that we make in all the mcu movies but
they he specifically said in this clip
they called them enhanced folks go ahead
and show the clip real quick john and
you went to a vendor con oh my gosh you
must have been mobbed by all your fans
no no you have a good time it was so fun
i mean the costume contest did get
cancelled but everybody said that i was
a front runner so and then the uh
enhanced individual tried to kill you
yes they enhanced individual which means
also
do we think this is them using the word
they've used enhanced before but do we
think this is the word that they're
using to say mutant instead yeah i mean
like they use you're right they said it
in uh age of ultron right when they were
talking about quicksilver and the
scarlet witch and called them like
enhanced so because they couldn't say
newton fox owned it and disney's not
known fox yet
that's been fixed yeah i was gonna say
what's stopping us now uh same mutant i
think that's also interesting
when in the she-hulk
muting in the she-hulk trailer we saw
them saying superhuman like
we're we're bringing on to defend
superhumans and not superheroes or super
villains just saying superhuman so it
seems like both terms are floating
around it i don't okay so if you look up
enhanced mutant or enhanced marvel
cinematic universe you'll probably be
taken to the fandom page
hey john's coming in this first yeah
yeah i was just on brandon's point they
also refer to her as a superhuman in
this episode
[Music]
anyways i'm done crying it's my party
but so what was i saying before john
interrupted oh no uh
the uh if you look up enhanced on like
the marvel fandom fandom page it gives
you like over 200 yeah because they
haven't narrowed it down so yeah they
haven't narrowed it down so if we were
to narrow it down would we be saying
that like uggos fatties okay
people with bad skins
shorties
bean poles
like for instance what would we call
like thor then because he's not he's a
god
maybe that's why they're mixing up their
terms and just have blankets chunky
hunkies for thor
because they haven't been able to really
have these classifications before but if
they're gonna have these are inhumans
these are mutants these are uh gods like
they could get more ticky tacky i think
someone does need to start journeying
down that road and separating them
because i think it's okay to keep the
word enhanced i just want to know who's
enhanced make me a flowchart yeah give
me a photo every day we're asking marvel
for give us some infographics here
it's more so like if enhance is just
people that are like iron man that has
just like the body suit to do it then i
understand that because that's
technically same with kamala but without
the
uh the bengals she isn't an enhanced oh
is that true
that's what they said we're gonna talk
about it it comes with from yeah
yeah he's just hitting on her though
do we expect to see humans introduced
into the mcu
in it i mean
i thought they wouldn't do it yeah i
feel like but they might do it yeah they
softened us up a little with black gold
and now they're doing this and i think
that that's their like their little
sneaky path forward
well chrissy comes in with the save as
usual goes away enhanced is having
heightened skills make sure this doesn't
disappear yeah yeah uh enhances oh my
god
good lord you're all tight
yeah enhanced is having heightened
skills endurance while still having
human dna and biology mutants have
heightened skills and endurance but it's
due
to a mutation of their dna which changes
their biology that makes sense thank god
someone is smart so i was an enhanced
individual at a third eye blind blind
concert one time i uh a person gave me
uh gave me a pill and i was enhanced for
about three hours yeah you were hard for
somebody no no no no my skills and
endurance
i was singing i was singing along no
perfect wish you would step back from
that ledge my friend remember them you
guys weren't boring i wasn't born as i
remember no we weren't born yet whitney
we're young okay
no we are 22. so um someone said
pre-tape you go to hell
don't answer the trashers who say it's
yeah you're worse than garbage sir your
garbage disposal mints meat but like
whitney said the powers do come within
like bruno said we also have the little
clip to prove to tommy go ahead and play
it
so it looks like your power isn't coming
from the bank
it's coming from within you
like the bengal are not the superhuman
part of you
that's very important it's coming from
within you
okay first of all that was like the
quickest that they could have possibly
explained yeah
it was very the script probably had like
a paragraph before and they were like
dude it's too long you have to whittle
it down and it wasn't thank you that was
super efficient the most positive show
was great because it was so efficient i
was like here's her training she's
already good at it there you go uh
here's also how she got her powers oh
great perfect thank you
that was 90s movie level efficient
explaining where they would be like
there's an asteroid headed to earth
bigger than the size of texas and then
that's all you know yeah what do we
think with the department of damage
control being the okay you guys clearly
know what side i'm on not damn the
damage of the
department of damage control because not
only did they like also help out peter
parker um and then didn't and then
blamed him for the crime he did not
commit and then had to clean up all the
mess they do a bunch of stuff wrong
first and then they figure it out are
they even what's the damage they're
gonna even do in miss marvel that we
expect well i you know if you tune into
big questions oh oh we really go we
really go deep on the dodc and their
origins and where they're heading
because they are gaining a lot of power
within the mcu uh we've seen it movie to
movie they get a little more power the
dodc and they're kind of like the new
shield in a lot of ways they used to be
under shield they were a part of shield
and then they got turned into their own
department by the executive branch of
the government so like oh my god they
have a lot more power now and now that
shield's gone because they're all most
of them were hydra uh they're kind of
working on their own and they have a lot
of ability and agency thanks to the us
government do you remember the company
that monica
worked for what they were called do they
work closely with them
because they're both doing alien sort
like sword it was a sword what was it
it wasn't
did they change the acronym to something
else i thought it was something
different that the the the the the white
we got you we got sword we got
it
it was sort of okay i was like maybe i
was wrong okay do you think so they work
under them or above the way i was
thinking about it was that like they're
separate and sword if you think about
like the fbi and the cia the fbi works
domestically the cia's supposed to work
internationally
supposed to
hey
camera
but uh if you think about it this way
like think about like the doc dc
handling stuff on earth for the us
government and sword is more worried
about the big dogs the omega level
threats oh yeah like the dojc doesn't
have time to worry about scrolls and
they're going to uh scrolls and like
aeroshim and all that that's like swords
problem right and like aliens and all
that but if they get on u.s soil then
it's like the dod i love that they're
just like going after high schoolers
right now
they're just like let's get peter parker
get a lawyer get a lawyer kid bullying
all children get a lawyer seriously you
guys don't want to get a lawyer this is
america but i all you got to say is am i
free to go am i my friend
am i being charged with a crime am i
being charged with a crime the thing is
there's still teens in new york and the
teens in new york don't know what the
laws are let me tell you about it i
didn't know and i'm not even from new
york you know what's happening to the
world today back in the newsies time
those kids do a lot front to back they
knew when they were being taken
advantage of by the paper owners
they did they did they went on strike
go ahead in the chat and give us all
your questions that you might have for
the miss marvel episode two yes uh we
have our enthusiast jessica here um
tommy well tommy star wars i said you
speaking in the third person that's star
wars i'm everything tommy's a stylist
i'm baseball all i care about is
baseball and you want to know what last
night i fell asleep watching baseball on
my delicious
helix mattress oh
that's right what a segway the surgeon
general recommends you get 14 hours of
sleep at night and last night was no
difference for me uh hit me over on
camera three for a second i want to just
get some information out i want to thank
my best friends at helix for sponsoring
us today as i've said before i am the
owner of a helix mattress and it is
decadent it allows me to sleep soundly
so i can create all these mandatory fun
segments that i wish
wish i could be around a host
i've told uh everyone here that i hate
my roommates and at this point it's
reaching a fever pitch for me
joey i'm begging you
camera four throw away the salmon okay
it's been 12 days the smell is
permeating
the it's breaching the seal of the
refrigerator and the refrigerator is new
okay salmon is meant to last two maybe
three days after it's freshly caught and
clean
at this point it's not salmon anymore
joey it's not even ceviche it's just
it's just slime
[Laughter]
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else as
a prank it's not april fool's with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and as i've said
that's not true at least forty percent
of you are basic
you're so basic so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses i like it to be like a slab
of concrete when i lay down smacking me
back up fourth from whence i came
but
they also have soft infrared medium as i
said now if you sleep hot they got
cooling mattresses mattresses great for
spinal alignment to prevent those
morning aches and pains you get once you
turn 22 that's right it's over after
your 21st birthday that's when you start
to slow descent into death and let's
hope it's slow because if it's fast
you're only getting half a life
helix mattress even has a big mattress
for plus size sleepers you know you're
big body boys like me you know what if
you're a two burrito a weak guy get
yourself a plus size mattress that's me
just go to helixsleep.com break room
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life now here's the good
stuff helix is offering up to two
hundred dollars for all mattresses for
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
break room that's up to 200 on your
mattress order and two free pillows
that's one for your gourd and one for
your sword okay for all of our listeners
at helixsleep.com
breakroom
beautiful thank you for that tommy we
also want to remind everyone to check
out newrockstarsmerch.com
right now you can grab our latest
obsession shirt inspired by miss marvel
the beautiful show with a beautiful
design look at it isn't it adorable uh
and when you buy this shirt you will
unlock the opportunity to get a custom
shout out which will appear on inside
marvel our miss marvel after show hosted
by eric voss and mr taymond himself wow
check out all of our awesome marc
joffman merch options
happens a pound uh at
newrockstarsmerch.com that's from my
mary poppins
i wanted to continue with you but i know
that we need to pay attention to a
little topic
oh we're doing fine on time
this show's got four minutes left colin
oakland 20 bucks no question just want
to share my love to you all everyone on
the staff as well colin we appreciate
you colin what a super trash person yeah
colin you know what you're a little
bundle of trash i want to hold in my
heart
all right joe furstenberg also sent in a
super chat asking do you think a mutant
will be in thor love and thunder and how
are they brought in is no one else
low-key hoping bruno is a little
you know
and then i think i believe it's the
painting i completely am thinking i
completely am i want that part to be
taken out of the comic book line and
completely make him like a queer figure
in this oh okay dude i don't think yet
is is this a spoiler if i say another
comic thing
i don't know they've been warned
the banners up zoe um in the comics is
and it comes out gay
down the line and you can hate her all
you want for what she did in the past
but when she comes out as queer in the
comics it's a very everyone's allowed to
change everyone's allowed to make good
for their past mistakes listen there was
a time in my politician yeah exactly
politicians must pay forever when i was
a kid i wasn't the best some people
might even say i was a regular trash bag
myself but i rose out of the trash and
into the recycling bin
speaking of recycling bins it's time for
a segment that happens every single day
that's right it's mandatory fun
oh
there's the graphic you didn't have to
ask for it that was nice thank you john
may i please have my graphic again
he's been so kind oh wow what a sweet
one
thanks john you're the best would it
kill you to do it one more time
this is true now you're confusing
wonderful
i don't trust this guy you're simply
aces behind that switchboard over there
and if i could be so bold a fourth time
for the graphic please
oh my gosh i don't i'm very nervous by
this kindness that's it
now it's time for mandatory fun
thor for loving thunder is entering
uncharted territory oh yeah it's going
to be rated pg-13 sure yeah okay so the
usual dams and hacks will be thrown out
but this one's a little different
because the world four is rated pg-13
for partial nudity oh that's right the
gluteus maximus will be shown as seen in
the trailer blurred out we're thinking
it's going to be heard out and we're
going to be heard on when that
throw them away
comes out so
i said
get my three best friends gathered
around for mandatory fun
and uh let's delve into the sexier side
of the geekdom let's do a little
pg-13 fan fiction now a reminder for
everyone watching at home this is pg-13
yeah okay we're not going already yeah
yeah if you got a 12 year old in the
room you don't have to
you know close their eyes they can this
ain't gonna get too bad hang on i'm so
sorry guys this is horrible what's
happening what's going on just hang on
one second i'm really sorry this is so
embarrassing
hello what tommy what is happening
an accident at the zoo
god it's an animal body party the
giraffe pancreas is ready
all right i have to come right now
you can't get a giraffe's pancreas
doctor i'll be there i'll be too big for
you guys i am so sorry
i cannot host tommy today's mandatory
function
this
good news though i had actually
pre-asked someone to fill in no just in
case because i didn't know if uh that
pancreas you know they you know it's
like a it's like when you're adopting a
baby you never know when that thing's
gonna slide out
that thing yeah do you say when you
adopt a baby yeah when you adopt a baby
you never know when it's gonna slide out
and suddenly you're dead okay that's how
it works right how's that get out okay
so anyway i'll be back
uh a lot of people offered that super
chat we had
i can see you in the background tommy
it's incredible uh
well that's the camera person
go to camera
some people in the chat are saying and
that question about the mutant you want
to see indoors so many people are saying
storm we want to see storm babies
don't go to that camera why would you do
that okay i can sneak up in the camera
they want to see stars you guys want to
see storms you want to see storms i
could try to be
i thought you were dead i thought you
got stabbed no what happened to you i
faked my death oh okay and now i'm here
for mandatory fun
those eyes yeah
oh that's my audio
probably awful i would imagine i didn't
like normal humans i breathe out of my
belly button oh okay
now
i've asked each of you to prepare
the marvel fan of some geek fan fiction
okay of the pg-13 variety yes
however unfortunately
i can't be here to host the segment you
can't be here but i have found a host
that can help out we'll get in here soon
we're also our super what happens when
we just do mandatory fun and challenges
keeps changing
our sweat jar
190 we're ten dollars off from hitting
our 200 level i think because these are
going to be very pg-13 oh hey guys oh
star wars star lords oh it's me
everybody's favorite destroyer of uh
movies by being uh angry and over
brewing for no reason blame you for that
oh i blame myself i blame myself every
day uh anyway uh can i touch your mask
yeah sure oh that's nice nice
you can touch my mask
no i'll end it with that no no
i've been told this is mandatory fun
where tommy gets his three best friends
together to do something that is not
optional but it's still fun yeah today
we're doing some pg-13 fanfic yeah yeah
we're gonna do some geek fanfic uh that
we would like to see these movies
haven't been risque enough
what what i'm so sorry these would push
them more okay no you don't know
someone take his phone john takes no
john take his phone
all the way up there
the nova corps they're back together
they're all down upside down again okay
don't worry about it guys that was uh
that wasn't that was a wrong number oh
okay all right brandon uh why don't you
go first and read your phone i'll read
i'll read my fanfic uh this is what i'd
like to see in like a more pg-13 leaning
a little risque with a little a little
touch of nudity uh uh in in in the mcu
we're so close to breaking that 200 on a
swear jar i think if we do
someone should be allowed to spice
theirs up yes and i think it should be
one of the girls you're probably one of
the girls because maya and i was gonna
okay
my mine involves a little robot boy we
all know named division oh
uh vision goes into his room after a
long hike with wanda he returns to his
room to undress unbeknownst unbeknown to
him there's an open laptop on the
dresser
as he pulls his shirt from his sweaty
synthetic body the laptop whirs to life
though the screen remains blank a red
light near the webcam blinks slowly
there's not a person watching no name
we're not well not a person anymore but
merely a string of code no nozzola
oh he watches vision undress
as vision peels away more of his humong
clothes he suddenly stops
he turns to the camera and viz says
you know i can sense you oh
but he doesn't stop undressing and
begins to phase through his pants
revealing his shiny
red
[Music]
wow
that was real wow it's like the idea of
him phasing through his pants yeah
that's really hot guys wow you guys have
a lot of fun on this show yeah damn well
i just happen to have a little fanfic on
me at all times okay so i'll read it
yeah this is always in my pocket
you're late
the voice in the shadows called out to
abomination
abomination he replied
in an instant
nebula had him in a headlock but this
time
he wasn't being strangled no
this time
he was being choked
about
into the quiet streets of earth 838 oh
oh to be continued oh
i hear these i okay i can't wait to read
mine can i remind you yeah you can read
your show so mine is called neil
and neil like the name neil no no let
her do it sorry star-lord let me do this
um it's my fan fiction about
uh the third sister riva and lord vader
oh okay okay
i know though i know i'm more capable
stronger wiser i'm still left silent and
cold in this lonely ship at his command
i enter and he doesn't have to say a
word his dark eyes have already stripped
me of my decency
whoa he must feel the same way because
his breathing has quickened through his
machine regulated mask
yeah there it is
it is it is my great honor to be invited
aboard lord vader my skin is hot fire to
touch i'm beginning to lose my senses
i'm embarrassed i've never felt this way
about someone before what is this that's
when he finally says
neil
neil is a great name for some fan fans
this was written from the last episode
now re-watch the last episode of kenobi
and think of my fanfic
hey thank you thank you to our super
chatters we did break 200 uh dancing if
we can run a quick poll between i think
it should be jessica or whitney who gets
to add a little more to their story yes
absolutely i want to cut out people on
the chat again
don't don't let star lord i can't
promise you no mine would be terrible
why does it get any better
okay i'm gonna read mine okay so i went
hard opposite today you guys because
before
every this show and now rogue theory
they tell me
you can't you can't say that and so
brandon to me was like nothing too dirty
and i promised i wouldn't and so i i
didn't okay
baby groot arrives on earth 2f2f a world
apart from other worlds a multiverse
where vin diesel is actually dominic
toretto and paul walker is an immortal
being tyrese gibson is still roman
pierce in every way except that he's
also now the detective slash car thief
investigating dr michael morbius yes as
groot grows from a baby to a man in this
strange new land he aspires more and
more to be like vin diesel after many
years and several hobbs and shaw
spin-offs later groot and dominic meet
for the first time
and what i can only describe is a
reverse pinocchio
[Laughter]
wishes that he could be free to sway in
the wind like a tree and ask the gods
and ask the cats to switch their places
by playing kate bush running up that
hill real loud the next thing dominic
knows he has the cool tree oh he has
cool tree pecks with intricately woven
branches in a braided spiral for nipples
opens his eyes and realizes that he has
real adult man nipples for the first
time they high five but their nips are
now in focus so oh it's pg-13 oh that
was very pg good job i'm very proud of
you also
the name roman pierce sounds like it
belongs in a fantastic sure does it
sounds like it come on uh i think the
chat wants a little more neil yeah yes
please give us the epilogue to neil do
you have what happens next you don't
understand i read a lot of fan fiction
as a normal adult woman
i can't just improvise a story to you i
need to write it like well how like how
would
usually when he says
oh baby this is also just when i watched
the episode what i was thinking if if i
was third sister um i wanted to say neil
if you guys have watched uh season two
of flea bag when she comes out of that
room and he says neil i want him to grab
my face and then he says the third the
third sister yeah oh sorry sorry yeah
this would be your job
i want to grab the third sister's face
and then he goes leave to everybody in
the room
well they're on the deck of
the starbucks
when he said neil they all hurt
and she kneeled in front of everybody
and then he said leave and they all
scatter and he rubs her face and he goes
down to his buckle on his butt
and he starts to unlatch and then you
see that
dirty deep
dirty burnt stuff
oh no i forgot
he has a weird dick now
yeah it's definitely burnt
uses it he out protection so you don't
really see him oh okay that's a great
kind of well that's very kind of
uh lots of great super chats out there
that helped us get over 200 thank you so
much john cuss people out in the chat
because i didn't get too dirty for you
guys uh nina yes jessica [ __ ] yes nina
um a monkey man monkey [ __ ] yeah jess
is the bestest so are you maybe mad
gotham i [ __ ] love you well we got we
got some great super chatters john
greener said that should have been
paddington fanfic i'm upset
is he a child i don't know how we don't
we don't cry
pedro saying oh my god bringing you back
to my fanfic days it's never too late to
go back yeah filmed you're saying take
it
take that as you well thank you uh
spamaran great name saying outdoorsy
stuff with mark museums with stephen etc
uh joshua blaylock saying thanks for
doing what you do i watch every day and
look forward to it hope you like the
fanfic uh and this one miss mack daddy
uh saying who in the mcu do you think
have boned or should bone
love you jess hashtag black girl magic i
already said it cap and nat obviously
boned in the winter soldier and you guys
can if you don't see it they come out of
the shower together basically it's
impossible
it's impossible well that's like
implying you just saw his old dead best
friend again he needs to let off some
steam it didn't have to be bone-in could
have been just keep a
handstand good hand stuff what if it was
just hand stuff i know
i know
even though he thinks she's ugly and the
bug lady yeah yeah yeah gardens
like she's put a move on drags and drags
it's probably put a move on
this is really embarrassing
yes
okay i could go
uh guys i gotta go uh i'm gonna stand up
slow and kind of hunched over oh
[Applause]
tommy how's your pancreas oh uh well
it's draftified
oh well i hope that was fun guys i was
really sorry to miss that oh that's how
was the night king the night king was
fine i just think
he seemed stressed out oh yeah maybe a
little claustrophobic
i think i think he could have breathed
about the night he didn't finish the
segment no he had to go he got a call oh
that's crazy now he switched with stars
oh well that seems weird i didn't even
call star-lord so he was just hanging
out he was just ready to go he's ready
to go at any time
maybe maybe god called him i don't know
hey
it's time for today's break room
breakdown
what a graphic uh today's break room
breakdown is all about eric voss's
missible details from episode two of
miss marvel
and where he talks about the origins of
kamala khan's powers let's take a look
at that clip
youssef explains how maniva's mother was
caught up in all that a toddler on the
last train out of a station and got
separated from her parents nobody knows
how a little toddler
managed to get back on the train just
before the train pulled out of the
station i like how amir completes this
part of the story but then yusuf turns
to kamala to finish the second part of
the story about how the toddler made it
back to her father she followed a trail
of stars
right back to her father
[Music]
and i like how there's some subtle
musical chimes here like it was some
cosmic magic at play in this history a
trail of stars referring to cosmic
intervention cree tech inhumans that
sana and her mother aisha use to survive
first of all protect yusef at all costs
yeah so right if he
dies
david lynch style and kill someone i
will crawl through the tv like the girl
from the ring
she got that i go in exactly i will
crawl through the tv like the looney
tunes in space yes
so in that clip eric speculates that the
trail of stars comet is referring to a
cosmic origin of her powers possibly
create intervention or inhuman terrorism
myths like activation uh do we think
that this trail of stars could be like
hard light like the power that uh kamala
has yeah
who do you think did it uh i think
whoever made i think whoever made the
trails this would have been for uh
kamala's grandmother
i think it was her great grandmother who
is this like shunned snake woman or
whatever people called her the snake i
think she made it because she was going
back to her space man and she was like
go go with your dad get back on the
train i gotta get out of here uh bye
paceman spaceman spaceman spaghetti
oh doctors for germany
yeah i mean yeah that makes sense yeah
you know i just want to say we got about
uh you know
seven minutes left in the show we're
about halfway to 300. if we get to 300
we will dedicate
a barrage a four-way barrage of swear
words at the person who puts us over
that mark so you will get what i call
the the four-headed swears of duke if we
get to three hundred if not just put it
up there it's like if i do maybe cut off
one of our heads the other three i'll
keep swearing that's right
i'll post the second part to my fan
fiction whoa
310.
wait maybe that's too low no i like it
but 10 more dollars
we're like npr right now we're like and
a tote bag if we get to 315 i'll explain
what a real reverse pinocchio oh my gosh
i don't want it and if we get to 3 20
i'll show hole
there's too many there's too many
pinocchio movies coming out for me to
know what i'm pronouncing
i'll show you a starlight listen we're
talking about the stars of the light
from kamala's family
[Laughter]
i'm losing it i'm losing it um
if if she's like related to cree or
something like that do we think that
like her great-grandma had the same
powers
or are kamala uh kamala's powers like
manifesting in the way
that eric has kind of speculated that
she's imagining them these type of
powers like these are how captain
marvel's powers work and that's why
do you think people get whatever powers
they want
out of super chat we're getting super
chat now
oh god
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you theodore harris and brain stew
we'll end this show with a ton of curses
uh for sure yes okay what the [ __ ] is up
with
with kamala okay
i i like this idea that she is like
somehow part free and this is an inhuman
thing and they're gonna like i i thought
they would never do the inhumans in the
mcu yeah because it was something they
brought back it is from older comics in
the 60s but they kind of brought it back
when marvel didn't have the rights to
the mutants and they stopped making
x-men comics much to my chagrin i
[ __ ] loved x-men comics uh they
stopped making x-men comics they started
stopped making new mutants uh not both
the comic and the concept of new mutants
and they focused on in humans because it
was something marvel owned and they
could make shows and movies about it
they didn't want to make stuff about
x-men in the comics because they
couldn't control the movies
i uh i really like the cree idea and
sticking to the comics but i also think
that kevin feige would save that like
situation for his own being like you
know i don't think they would throw it
at the first like because i feel like
the first season to any new mcu show
they're like really just being like oh
does it stick to the wall um and this
one does stick to the wall but i think
he's saving that that opening for
something else so i'm still writing the
fact that uh even someone in the chat
said she might be celestial oh
i'm so i i can write any other idea than
cree right now because they're gonna
save it that is that was interesting
like how star-lord was like part
celestial the concept of celestials can
be these big giant space robots but they
can also manifest in different ways
little baby boys
do we know if the eternals can mate and
make a
offspring that's half we don't know that
we know they maybe we have these oh yeah
we do
uh but
i would assume that aaron would be smart
enough when he builds these robots to
not give them the ability to
procrastinate okay so it happens because
that's gonna completely change
everything and you gotta imagine in the
thousands of years on earth they were
like well let's try
let's see
what happens they were definitely doing
it at the right
at any of the seven wonders of the world
do you think icarus was like sorry babe
i don't have a condom they haven't been
there oh yeah nobody better i got a
sticker why do you know what it's called
then
did i say condom i'm a candle no it's
like a canned
um yeah uh another thing to think about
is what do we think aisha see the mouse
yeah aisha
um uh
uh kamala's grandmother
what what why do you think she's kind of
like evasive about this whole story
what's she hiding from it i think it's
such a big deal also i i this is my
dad
i think that
and this is i'm speaking mainly for like
me as a black person with a black family
when someone does something really
astronomical bad but it's not really bad
on the outside looking in just bad
culturally bad uh we kind of shunned
them
so it's like something that we don't
want to like like my cousin keisha for
instance she's watching this hey keisha
for a long time you know why we haven't
seen you in a long time whoa
keisha reconciliation confirmed exactly
but uh it's it's like it's still that
like well we just don't talk about it
right we don't we don't talk about bruno
we don't talk about this so i think it's
that same situation of like she did
something astronomic like astronomically
bad but it wasn't actually that bad well
and i like that idea in the sense that
like no one even knows what she did it's
just that like
kamal's grandmother aisha knows that
like something bad my mother did
something bad the whole neighborhood
talks about it i don't know what it is
but it's bad and so when she's raising
her own daughter muniba
and i'm sure maniva had questions about
her grandmother and her own mother's
like we don't talk about my
my mother it's bad don't even bring it
up i'm just gonna get us to america
we're gonna get you to america and
everything's gonna be great right well
the chat overwhelmingly thinks it's cree
tech guys by the way the bracelet yeah
that's a landslide i mean i i like this
idea that i know you think it's early
and frankie's maybe holding off but if
we're gonna get to eventually to secret
invasion i think it's going to be more
nuanced than just like the squirrels are
here and they're pretending to be people
because they've introduced the scrolls
in the mcu as like nice for the most
part and persecuted which was a total
reversal from what they've been how
they've been portrayed in the comics
most of the time
so i i think this secret vision thing
should involve both cree and skrulls and
kind of this weird thing and then the
humans are just like what's going on
what is that uh someone said did someone
say oh sorry i thought we were
transitioning keep going no no i had
nothing
someone said
did someone say stinky little trash boy
that brings us to let's get let's hammer
some of these food mr krabs is it
possible for modoc to be in charge of
the dodc or are they all scrolls what a
[ __ ] dumb idea that was mr krabs what
a stupid suggestion you little piece of
[ __ ]
all right we gotta we gotta roast them
as we do we gotta we gotta roast our
main people that put us over said will
we get more training montages what the
[ __ ] do you think of course of course we
gotta [ __ ] use training montages
hang on but we gotta hit our main people
can we put up in the chat who the people
who donated 50 and a hundred are because
we got we even had quotes but i'll put
them up here no but we're going to roast
their asses brain stew
you ought to be [ __ ] ashamed of
yourself [ __ ] you jose mercado ice cream
on pizza sounds disgusting
i'm going to step on you and you'll
probably enjoy it but i won't yeah
i'm gonna break you over my knee like a
wrestler yeah like every batman comic
book i'm going to you trash bags
you pieces i do like the storm virgil
going after brain stew playing stop it
please think of the children they don't
want you to show whole time
oh yeah sorry storm virgil you [ __ ]
clown
you proud so guys i'm uh [ __ ] tapping
in and we're tapping you out yeah so
orgasms
crazy josh gamer hey from south africa
what is wilson my mom
that they confiscated well isn't that a
[ __ ] shitty fancy idea yeah
when brandon cusses anyone else sounds
like adorable
you sound like sweet oh billy butcher
and the boys oh yeah
she wants a little slobby
you think i'm glad you killed [ __ ]
becca
aren't you just a horny little slob knob
putting all these winky holes
[Music]
loves everything about mandatory fun
but we [ __ ] hate it because it's
mandatory yeah no one likes mandatory
fun down with it i'm cancelling
mandatory fun
no don't cancel it all right
from that poll we ran earlier we asked
where do you watch your marvel disney
plus shows
47 of you said the television god
bless you yeah these zoomers out there
watching things on their phones are
ruining stuff for everybody right
you got to watch these things on your
television is honestly i really liked
the show on quivi dummy dummy
was [ __ ] amazing
cody heller wrote it and she's so
[ __ ] funny so in defense of that of
dummy yeah that's the show one show
everyone should watch defensively
download quibby right now i
think that people want to watch stuff on
their tv and not on their phones
[Applause]
porn and that is the only thing i'm
allowed to be watching we gotta we gotta
we gotta go here but i just wanna say
real quick mom i'm sorry oh yeah sorry
i'm [ __ ] sorry mom right i didn't
mean to
let's all apologize for our moms yeah
everybody apologize to you
oh god that's already i started off back
you gotta hurt me
oh god i called my mom writer first name
what terrible child am i oh god okay
well go next i already made her upset
hey hey mom uh i was a relatively good
kid but that's senior year in high
school i got a little rebellious so i
apologize for that but i love you and i
support you
no one else no i got one hi mom it's
whitney um i have purple hair which you
hate a and b the other day you came over
to my house to drop off your dog and you
walked into my apartment and you said
have you been smoking pot in here and i
said no
but that wasn't true
that was a lie i'm sorry uh we love our
moms we love our moms love our mom we
love all of you
you're super trash thank you so much for
tuning in today and each and every day
happy 616 to all of you we'll be back
tomorrow it's friday tomorrow i'm
purposely not going to be here because
these kids get a little too crazy i got
one word for you oh my gosh
tommy's been buying supplies all week i
implore you to turn in tomorrow oh my
god and i please keep these children
safe they're going to beg you for super
chat don't give them to them if it leads
to drinking more because these babies
i'm not going to do it they have so few
brain cells
and two of them oh you lots of fanfic
now thank you to you generously yes we
love you have a great rest of your
thursday watch the boys tonight tune in
to the boys underground tomorrow eric's
breakdown of obi-wan kenobi episode 5
will be up on the channel soon uh
it's what it's out stop watching this go
watch that watching this go we love you
all goodbye